well there is an award-winning pizza
spot that's all about being hungry and
happy rocky stopped by the sponsors of
this next segment don demarco's to learn
more
it is always a pizza party here at dom
demarco's pizzeria in bar and summerlin
and albert you were the owner of this
fine establishment it's always a party
but especially monday through friday
right absolutely
absolutely if you're a happy hour person
then you should be at don demarco's and
i'm gonna tell you why okay i'm
listening
from monday to friday from two to six
we have fifty percent off all lines by
the glass
bottle and draft beers and all well
cocktails in addition to that we have
four items that are usually fourteen
dollars on our end on our menu we sell
for seven dollars eggplant passats
chicken wings 12 inch cheese pizza for
seven dollars
and a beautiful caesar salad for seven
dollars we even go beyond that we have
what we call the happiest of happy hours
between two and four p.m
is 50 off all bottles of wine any bottle
of wine 50 off and all pizzas any pizzas
50
so we're all about having a good time
here at don demarco's and the happy hour
is the best i love it and because you
guys have the freshest ingredients for
your pizzas
at the bar the same thing here at the
bar
jared tell you all about that all right
let's hear it so just like albert said
he and chef alex strive for the highest
quality fresh ingredients in the kitchen
and i try to mimic that behind the bar
whenever possible good the way we do
that is by doing our our own vodka
infusions we've got the fresh fruits we
do strawberry blueberry orange lemon
raspberry uh calabrian chili anything
that we can do behind the bar ourselves
make in-house we try to do we do our own
lemon cello we make our own cinnamon
whiskey we barrel age cocktails
just try to keep it fresh and high
quality i love that now what do you
think pairs best with just the classic
pizza here the classic pairing is
definitely a beer uh but i'm a cocktail
guy first and foremost so i recommend a
key lime martini pretty good
okay well then i think we should go
ahead back to the kitchen and
start whipping up the pizza all right
alex the dough is stretched yes it is
just tell me before i before i make
the famous dom demarco pizza who is don
the godfather
dom is an innovator of pizza
a lot of people do respect them
throughout the country
a lot of people know about them
what he's very known for is being very
meticulous with his pizzas best
ingredients
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's see if i make don proud
look at that pizza nice cheese nice
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to dom demarco pizzeria for
sponsoring this segment enjoy their
happy hour every monday through friday
from 2pm to 6pm for more information you
can just go to domdemarcos.com